[Musique]
pour cet épisode de service click
j'aimerais qu'on prenne nos idées reçues
qu'on les mette bien au chaud de côté
parce que j'aimerais qu'on aborde cette
question de manière un peu différente
le mois dernier donald trump a été élu
45e président des états unis
défiant tous les pronostics pas la
majorité des électeurs
enfin la majorité je n'étais pas
tellement parce qu'ils étaient lus par
seulement 25 points 5 % de la population
américaine 25% de la population
américaine qui aura un impact sur le
destin du monde sa mousseline alors
l'une des raisons est ce n'est
évidemment pas la seule c'est que 46% la
population américaine s'est abstenu de
voter alors je ne veux pas tomber dans
le travers classique du c'est la faute à
l'abstention mais plus attirer votre
attention
cette tendance de fond car dans pas mal
de nos sociétés l'abstention est à la
hausse en france par exemple prenons
deux dates 1958 et 2012
entre ces deux dates le taux
d'abstention passe pour les
présidentielles de 15 à 20% pour les
municipales de 26 à 3 9% et pour les
législatives de 25 à 45 % à autant vous
dire que ça monte ça monte et que comme
le niveau des océans ça n'a pas l'air
parti pour s'arrêter alors qui sont les
personnes qui s'abstiennent
et pour quelle raison le font-elles
s'agit-il comme le sous entend de
certains nos politiciens de fainéants de
gens non d'informer non politisés ou
peut-être même trop fatigués de leur
biture de la veille pour aller voter oui
merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
n'était pas la partager
carrément pas les abstentionnistes sont
comme les votants ils agissent par
conviction et les listes quelques
raisons franchement du team qui
expliquent que leur nombre augmente la
sensation que nous gouvernants ne nous
représentent plus en est une
si on regarde l'origine
socioprofessionnelle de ces derniers
aujourd'hui en france 80 2 % des
parlementaires sont cadres versus 13% de
la population et 50 2 % des français
sont employés ou ouvriers versus 3 % des
députés coïncidence incroyable
une bonne partie des abstentionnistes
fait partie des classes défavorisées
c'est une population qui se sent plus
représenté dans une démocratie
représentative
puis s'abstenir de voter je vous avoue
alors ce qui aussi désagréable que la
sensation de ne pas être représenté
c'est la censure de ne pas être écoutés
pour certains la démocratie est devenue
une machine à désespérer que diriez vous
si demain alors j'invite toute la france
à donner son avis lors d'un grand
référendum genre
chocolatines versus pains au chocolat
que je voulais c'est tous voté que tout
le monde voter et qu'à la fin je décide
de ne pas tenir compte de votre avis
pour prendre des décisions à l'encontre
du résultat de ce référendum ce serait
pas très très gentil et franchement
décourageant et bien c'est un peu ce qui
s'est passé lors du dernier référendum
national en 2005 pour l'établissement
d'une constitution européenne
on pourrait aussi parler des promesses
de candidat pour lesquelles les gens
votent mais sur lesquels ils n'ont aucun
contrôle une fois l'élection terminée
genre mon adversaire c'est la finance
mais ne sanctionnant pas la société
générale après laffaire dépanneur ben
voilà et ça arrive tout le temps du coup
ça permet de comprendre un peu un
certain découragement d'une partie des
français qui décide de ne plus voter
puisque de toute façon leur avis ne sera
pas pris en compte ils sont souvent plus
pour utiliser que ce que les votants
pourrait le penser mais ont
continuellement l'impression de devoir
choisir non plus entre deux alternatives
viables
notons pour à lavement et un sandwich ou
kaka surtout quand ces derniers sont
issus du même parcours
sciences po plus senna et semble s'être
orienté vers leurs partis plus par plan
de carrière que par conviction
oui mais six ruches tête rageur de
prendre la défense des abstentionnistes
ce n'est qu'une excuse
et pour se bouger pour aller voter blanc
quand même alors déjà à personne par
comme ça et ensuite la loi de 2014 à
donner de l'importance ou votre ben oui
et non ainsi la loi de 2014 à apporter
certains changements comme le fait que
les votes blancs soient désormais
comptabilisées séparément des votes nuls
ou qu'une enveloppe vide soit considéré
comme un vote blanc les changements
s'arrête là même si le vote blanc
faisait 90% des suffrages le candidat
avec 10% remporterait quand même
légalement l'élection ce qui décourage
clairement de se déplacer pour voter
même blanc et malgré tout ce que je vous
dis j'irai voter
je vais même jusqu'à vous inciter à le
faire pourquoi car même si tout a été
fait au fil des années pour nous
persuader que voter blanc est en
apparence identique à s'abstenir
le vote blanc a plus de poids qu'il n'y
paraît et 90% des gens qui votent blanc
à une élection auront toujours plus de
points que 90 % d'abstention pourquoi
qu'elle sera impossible aux gouvernants
de sous-entendre que sur 90% des votants
blanc 89 étaient probablement bourré de
la veille et avait oublié d'aller voter
il s'agira de 90 % de personnes qui sont
venues émettre une opinion car même si
90 % de votes blancs à une élection de
la nulle pas s'abstenir en masse non
plus l'idée répandue d'ailleurs que 75 %
d'abstention annuler une élection est
complètement pousse ainsi vous abstenez
en espérant atteindre ce nombre pour
faire sauter le système pouvait arrêter
c'est une énorme légendes urbaines en
fait contrairement au fait qu'il puisse
y avoir un crocodile dans les égouts de
paris
c'est vrai parce qu'au final ne pas
voter pour faire entrave au système
c'est une erreur on ne s'oppose pas au
système en ne votant pas on lui facilite
la tâche
le seul gagnant de cette situation où
l'abstention augmente ce sont ceux qui
gouvernent pour l'abstention c'est une
chance - la demande qui votent plus
c'est facile d'être élu et réélu une
abstention qui gagne du terrain
c'est à terme favoriser l'émergence de
deux catégories d'individus qui ne
pourront que s'éloigner les uns des
autres
il y aura d'un côté ceux qui pensent
voter pour des politiques à leur image
et de l'autre ceux qui ont moins voté
voire plus du tout ne pas voter ne fera
pas changer de système
c'est pas en restant allongé à côté
d'une rivière pour protester que tu
changeras le sens du courant parce que
l'abstention ne fait pas que le jeu du
fn et l'abstention aide tous les pourris
quels qu'ils soient à s'assurer de leur
élection
parce que oui 1 lens parle d'abstention
et vous pensez forcément aux
présidentielles qui arrivent mais quand
on voit le taux d'abstention aux
dernières législatives
alors qu'on connaît le rôle et
l'importance d'avoir de bons députés
on peut identifier l'une des causes qui
aggrave le problème de la
représentativité comme ceux qui sont
défavorisés ne vote pas leurs
préoccupations ne sont plus prises en
compte par les politiciens qui préfèrent
favoriser les gens qui peuvent assurer
leur réélection
et du coup concrètement par exemple au
premier tour de la législative partielle
dans l'aube un décembre 2014 et eu 75 %
d'abstention le candidat arrivé en tête
est arrivé avec 42 76% des voix
et si on rapporte ce chiffre au nombre
d'électeurs on se parle de 6600 une voix
le candidat au premier tour a recueilli
en terme de représentativité et de
légitimité
le vote d'un électeur sur dix ce qui est
clairement ridicule et ce n'est
malheureusement pas un cas à part
ainsi on regarde les dernières
municipales dans les trente plus grandes
villes en terme d'habitants les listes
électorales gagnante ne représentait que
3 électeurs sur dix au maximum
du coup il suffit de savoir quels
électeurs cajoler pour emporter une
élection comme la mairie de puteaux qui
offre chaque année des cadeaux aux
personnes âgées parce que même si je ne
me sens pas représenté
quoi qu'on dise tous les candidats ne
sont pas équivalents et non pas la même
symbolique un hollande à mélenchon un
juppé ou le pen
ça ne veut pas dire la même chose et ça
ne renvoie pas le même message à la
population par exemple lorsque trump
s'est fait élire il ya eu pendant
plusieurs jours une déferlante d'actes
racistes dans tout le pays dans tous les
états unis
car dans les multiples messages qui ont
envoyé les urnes
son élection il y avait aussi suivre et
au delà de tout ce qu'on a dit jusqu'à
présent
si tu ne le fais pas pour toi pas fait
le porte à neuf à qui on risque de
prendre des droits comme celui
d'apporter un vélo pour ton amie émigrée
qui risque de ne plus sentir aussi bien
chez lui fais le pour ton voisin qui
pensent que ces problèmes perso sont dus
à l'accueil dans son pays de
l'équivalent de 0 0 45% de la population
française ou au pire au pire fais le
pour moi jamais gentil et pour voter par
contre il faut être inscrit sur les
territoires et au pire même si vous
hésitez encore à voter inscrivez-vous
quand même parce que pour pouvoir voter
l'année prochaine il faut que vous soyez
inscrits et vaut mieux que vous vous
inscriviez pour ne pas voter que de
regretter l'année prochaine de ne pas
sur les listes
vous savez quoi on a fait ensemble ça
prend deux minutes
alors on commence par taper sur son
moteur de recherche favori s'inscrire
listes électorales on arrive sur le site
du service public
on saisit son code postal et on accède
aux services en ligne on sera un compte
ce qui prend approximativement apprécié
hâtivement 30 secondes à en scène les
divers formulaires qui ne demande aucune
information trop délicate attention
là on arrive à la partie sensible avec
le plus fort taux d'abandon
accrochez-vous un ok vous devez fournir
un scan d'autres cartes d'identité et un
justificatif de domicile je sais je sais
je sais c'est hyper volou fait une fois
et vous mettez ça dans un petit dossier
ça vous servira tout le temps tout
d'audi c'est très utile
ok moi je fais ça dans un petit dossier
chez ça comme ça c'est réglé
vous êtes inscrit attention il ne te
reste plus qu'une semaine pour effectuer
bardon il vous reste plus qu'une semaine
voilà parce que le 31 décembre on peut
plus s'inscrire après merci d'avoir
regardé cette vidéo
j'espère que vous a plu j'espère que cet
éclair maintenant vous pouvez reprendre
haute idée reçue et vous même vous avez
mieux que moi ce que vous voulez en
faire apprendre à garder la jetée voilà
voilà jeté à la morte
un grand merci aux types heures comme
d'habitude merci de soutenir ce projet
merci à vous je ne sais pas comment le
dire autrement ça fait vachement plaisir
merci
n'hésitez pas à me suivre sur facebook
twitter et staps jatte 1
parce que parce que j'aime beaucoup ça
peut-être voilà et twitter aussi
facebook aussi un esthète absolu et bien
comme d'habitude toutes les sources soit
en description vous faire un gros bisou